foreign
[Music]
so let's begin another
speedrun game incoming it's a 2108 GM
all right so we're going Sicilian
and as I explained two games ago I've
made kind of an interesting executive
decision which is
basically past 2100 to play my actual
opening repertoire so rather than going
with the accelerated Dragon which we've
had quite a bit of
um I'm going to revert back to the night
ORF and I think it's a win-win I'll
introduce the basic ideas of the night
or and obviously it's an opening that I
know really really well so you'll kind
of get another feather in your cap now
the previous time we faced Bishop B5
check and I got completely outplayed and
almost lost the game it was a really
fascinating video by the time you're
watching this on YouTube that video
should be up already
and here are opponent opts for the main
line which is called the open Sicilian
of course we take on D4
we developed the Knight to F6 and here
there is a major fork in the road first
of all white does not have to play
Knight C3
but does so in like 99 of cases
here there is a major fork in the road
the night off is the most popular
response it is followed by the sort of
second tier Sicilians the Rouser or the
classical Sicilian as Knight C6 and of
course the dragon the traditional dragon
is G6 but that's not all there are a
couple of other moves more obscure moves
E6 is the shenan again which I also
talked about in that other video
because we actually got that structure
through a different line
but that's still not it there is even
the Obscure move Bishop D7 which at one
moment was quite popular and there's the
cotton hour variation which is the
immediate E5 I'll show that line a
little bit after the game because E5
kind of fails on a tactical front but in
this game we play the night or A6 named
after polish Argentinian GM Miguel night
or if who breathed the most life into
the actual opening and since this is the
first time I'm playing the night or the
the body of theory that could be in that
could be talked about is is way way way
too fast for even a 10 hour long video
so I'm gonna have to restrict myself
essentially to what our opponent plays
because books have been written simply
on this one line white has seven or
eight uh incredibly theoretical and
dangerous continuations that range from
Bishop G5 to the Fisher attack with
Bishop C4 uh to more positional moves
like A4 and Bishop B2 I'll give you kind
of the the general menu maybe try to
give you a flavor for some of Black's
typical idea is after the game but here
we are facing What's called the English
attack and the English attack is defined
by this move F3 that white plays for two
purposes the first is obvious white is
securing the E4 Pawn but the second is
to prepare What's called the English
attack it's named after uh several
English Grandmasters who were kind of
the first to play this system regularly
after black Castle's King side White's
point is to run the pawns off the board
G4 G5 H4 Etc and that is why white
starts off by playing F3
here another fork in the road for black
the shenanigans structure is reached if
we play E6 but the type of night ORF
that I personally like to play a lot
more and I have a lot more experience
with that structure does anybody know
what the other main move is other than
E6 which leads to a fundamentally
different type of position these two
lines are have not a lot in common
believe it or not and the other move of
course is E5 immediately attacking the
Knight and if you're seeing all of this
for the first time if you're a newer
player watching this on YouTube I would
if I were you I wouldn't worry too much
about sort of trying to understand the
point of each move because this is like
opening Theory that's been known for
many many years and it's hard for me to
explain all of this from like first
principle so what you should focus on
right now is that this is opening Theory
I'll contextualize this after the game
but for now we just need to get to a
fresh position so here
following E5 we need to secure the D5
square that is of course the main
positional drawback of all night orbs
where you play E5 and so it makes sense
to bring the bishop out to E6 securing
the D5 score and preventing White's
Bishop from developing to C4 now we
continue developing our King side Bishop
E7 typically white plays Queen D2 in
order to prepare long castles and that's
why the night orph is such a fascinating
opening in many lines there is opposite
side castling this is the most kind of
traditional nidorphy type line where
black attacks on the queen side white
attacks on the king side now let's see
who watches my stream regularly because
in this position the main move by a
country mile is Knight bd7 G4 and then
B5 but there is a much more obscure move
that I really really like to play I've
played it successfully for
right about a year now in in online
Blitz and this is a move which was
popular about 15 years ago and I have
found that even top players are
completely clueless against this line
because yes black is worse if white
plays perfectly but if white makes even
one small misstep this line can lead to
Absolute crushing defeat in 20 moves and
the move I'm talking about
is not weird per se I think it makes
sense when you see it but it might seem
awkward because we've already played A6
and A6 seems to prepare B5 and that's
the main way to attack
but the move that I want to focus on is
actually a five I've played it over the
board I've played it hundreds of times
online and our opponent clearly still
bursts in this line Bishop B5 is one of
the best moves now the point of Bishop
B5 is to prevent black from playing A4
which would kick the Knight to this
ungodly Square on A1
but the drawback of putting the bishop
on B5 is that it can be vulnerable to
attack by the B8 Knight and here you
simply have to know the ideas of the
line in order to play it successfully so
here are the move is Knight A6 which is
probably not a move that you would
arrive at if you were looking at this
for the first time you would probably be
inclined to develop the Knight to C6 but
there is a very concrete point of Knight
A6 and that is to drop the Knight back
to C7 in order to dislodge this bishop
on B5 and if it is successfully
dislodged then we can continue storming
the queen side with A4
alternatively if white leaves the bishop
on B5 after an ic7 we get the bishop
pair and once the Knight leaves C3 this
is one of the main neither of ideas
across almost all variations you should
be aware that this move often is in
Black's favor particularly if you have
the bishop here what am I talking about
of course I'm talking about the central
breakthrough D5 which
makes sense positionally because it
eradicates the weak Square on D5 right
that is the way that you eradicate
weaknesses you like push upon and change
the structure and Z5 is no longer a weak
Square so D5 is a very kind of seminal
idea in this particular variation of the
night ORF as well as in most uh
variations of the night or of both
positional and Tactical
King B1 so that is a good move and of
course now we follow up with Knight to
C7 posing white with a dilemma this is
one of the lines in which white has to
know really like four or five moves of
relatively obscure Theory not just to
get a better position but if white
doesn't know it then white often ends up
like much much worse or or even lost so
I'm banking on the fact that our
opponent isn't like
wildly well versed in theory I play this
against Fabi in a title Tuesday game and
got a winning position out of the
opening so it's a little bit risky I
will reveal like some of White's best
continuations even though it works
against my interest after the game
but let's see how this turns out I still
think that you can play this line
successfully
um with black definitely an online Blitz
because even if I place down the best
line it's still very very hard to play
practically
yeah so here the main move is actually
Bishop E3 to B6 which
is not necessarily an obvious move it
well it sort of is if you if you
understand what you're looking for
Bishop B6 pins the Knight to the queen
and seems to permanently prevent a
problem of Knight takes B5 but in
response to Bishop B6 black guys I would
call it a sexy move
blackened unpin the Knight by moving the
queen and shifting it over from d8 over
to B8 Queen d8 to B8 and sometimes in
that line the queen can make its home on
A7 in certain situations but the main
point of Queen B8 is to re renew the
threat of Knight takes B5 so in some
ways I'm trying to like explain opening
Theory which is hard to do with an
opening as tactical as the night orphan
this is a a a small taste of why I did
not recommend the night or uh to newer
players right at the start of the speed
run the accelerated dragon is a much
more accessible Sicilian it's a little
bit less theoretical and it's easier to
understand like why you're putting the
pieces on the squares that you're
putting them almost the placement of
almost every piece can be explained
apriori whereas the night orph is just
such a tactical line that a lot of moves
they can be explained you can understand
why they're played but largely you have
to understand them through the lens of
studying a bunch of variations and then
the move starts to kind of make sense I
don't know if that explanation itself
makes sense but hopefully it gives you a
little bit of context okay so here I
have to remember the move because we
have two options the first is to push D5
and that has to be calculated the second
is to bring the Rook up to A6 which is
another very typical idea in this line
and kick this bishop away from B6
now the benefit of playing Rook A6 is
that if the bishop simply moves back to
E3 we play B5 and we win the game the
bishop on A4 is trapped
so after Rook A6
what is white planning what is our
opponent going to do well of course
white can take on C7 but generally
that's kind of a win for us like we want
the bishop pair we want to force white
to take on C7
now after Rook A6 I guess there is also
the move Queen to E3 in order to protect
uh the bishop on B6
that actually might be the best line I'm
pretty impressed with uh how our
opponent is handling handling this line
he knows a lot more than even some GM so
I'm pretty sure Rook A6 Queen E3 is to
be avoided which leaves us with the
other move D5
now we don't care about the A5 Pawn in
almost no cases are we concerned that
White's gonna take on A5 because that
merely helps our attacking cause it
opens up the a file and most of the time
white can't even get away with taking on
A5 because there's like too many hanging
minor pieces so I'm pretty sure the D5
is the better option here
I will be honest I don't know this
position like I'm out of book but D5
feels a very very exciting B in the
spirit of the position and C
I think confronts our opponent with
difficult practical problems so
on a basic level this move works as
follows it opens up the dark squirt
bishop and there are enough Defenders on
the D5 Square so we have one two three
uh minor pieces guarding it white has
one two three four pieces attacking it
but because the queen is in front after
e takes D5 Knight takes D5 Knight takes
D5 Knight takes D5 you know it's like
the fact that a queen is among the
primary attackers overrides the fact
that there are more attackers than
Defender so obviously their Queen takes
D5 is not possible because white drops
the queen
so of course white can win this Pawn by
first taking on C7 white can play Bishop
takes Knight eliminating a Defender and
then white can grab the pawn with uh his
own Pawn and in that position well in
that position we had the Tactical move
rook d8 in order to recover the pawn our
opponent takes on D5 with the Knight
okay we don't have much of a choice here
let's take back with a knight
and after Ed it makes the most sense to
take on D5 with a knight because if we
take with the bishop that doesn't come
with Tempo and remember again our
general approach here is to drive the
bishop out of B6 and already things are
getting a little bit difficult for white
because again if white plays Bishop F2
we move the pawn up to B5 and the game
ends immediately and I have won
countless games exactly in this kind of
way where White's just sort of
unsuspectingly moving pieces and
suddenly these minor pieces are actually
incredibly vulnerable to to a pawn storm
so I already think that white made a
rash move I think Knight takes D5 was
kind of an impulsive reaction I'm pretty
sure the bishop takes C7 has to be
played and now I'm starting to remember
that there's like a queen sack line
there that I'll show after the game
the fact that our opponent is starting
to think already tells me that he senses
that he's done something wrong
Queen F2 okay maybe not maybe this is
still Theory and I'm totally wrong
that's totally possible
Queen F2 makes the most sense
okay now we should not rush to grab this
bishop I know that in general I
explained that we want to remove this
bishop but if we take it the queen
replaces it and the queen is then going
to be pretty hard to dislodge from B6
let's see if we can play for maximum
here because if we force this bishop
away from B6 then we will in fact be
able to play B5 so what are the
alternatives to Knight takes pieces well
of course one of the reasons that we
play A5 is to guarantee the option of
Rook A6 so let's consider Rook to A6
okay so we hit the bishop the bishop has
to move it'll probably drop back to C5
in that line okay six Bishop C5
then we should not take on C5 because
white recaptures with a knight and uh so
it hits a rook it's our Bishop that's
awful so after Rook A6 Bishop C5 I think
it's important to notice that that
Bishop on E7 is protected by the Knight
so I think we can actually straight away
go B5
and if white plays Bishop takes C7 then
we can play Knight takes C7 but
unfortunately in that final position can
anybody spot a Tactical Defensive move
for white in that final position after
Rook A6 Bishop C5 B5
takes takes and then Knight C5
yeah Knight C5 is the move exactly very
good uh Misha
and then after Knight C5
I'm trying to figure out if we can pin
the Knight with a move like Queen to A7
then white plays Bishop takes B5 things
get very messy so let's do this again
okay six Bishop C5
B5
Bishop takes C7 can we play B takes a
four instead maybe that's a good
alternative
things get very very messy there
but it actually seems to me like we can
or at least we might be able to
sacrifice the exchange for a long-term
attack on the Kings on the Queen's side
technically the side of the board is
still the queen side even though White's
King is located there yeah Rook A6 is
too juicy not to play takes takes do we
have any interesting options there I
don't love Black's position after the
trade on B6 just because
we kind of stagnate on the king side of
this Knight is a very important attacker
sometimes it can jump to B4 or C3 so we
want to avoid giving it up if possible
okay let me do a little bit more
calculation silently and don't worry
like I'll explain all of this after the
game
but I just have to think
seriously
because the lines are incredibly
incredibly complex even for me I mean
this is the no joke
absolute no joke you can lose this with
one little inaccuracy
calculating an insane line
so there they're there Bishop has to
move where does it go it goes to C5
though
okay then we play BC Queen takes C2 Rook
C6
looks very dubious but it could be
rewarding so Rook A6 Bishop C5 B5 takes
it takes Knight C5
we can play Rook C6
then white plays 96 FB but should be
three four white plays Bishop B3
immediately we can play
um can't quite work it out okay but
let's go Rook A6 I feel like we have to
take up the gauntlet I've sunk way too
much time into this move to not play
Rook A6 at this point I've sucked I I've
sunk sunk way way too much time to then
just play Knight takes B6
but I I'm still not sure what I'm gonna
do after Bishop C5 B5 Bishop takes E7
because the option of stacking The
Exchange there is very enticing but it
leads to just complete and utter chaos
that's unevaluable like it's impossible
to say if black is winning black is
losing but my gut is that it's on sound
I feel like that exchange stack is on
sound so I think we're gonna go for the
simpler option of recapturing on E7 I
provided the white finds all of this
which is still not a given absolutely
not a given that white finds Bishop C5
I think some people would panic and like
play Rook takes D5 very typical Panic
reaction when you see that the b-pawn is
going to advance on the next move
um another panicky move would be like
Knight C5 oh let's try to complicate
things but Knight C5 just loses the game
and uh it loses because after Rook takes
B6 Knight takes E6 another complicated
question for you guys does anybody see
Black's winning move there so if I place
Knight C5 Rook takes B6 and Knight takes
E6 what's the winning intermezzo
consider the placement of The Rook on B6
and what it's doing yeah it's actually
Knight C3 check and then you take the
Rook on D1 attacking the queen
it's not Rook takes C6 because that
leaves the Knight on C5 exposed
and it's actually not F take C6 because
white plays Rook takes D5 removing the
defender and the queen makes contact
with the Rook so just crazy lines there
our opponent is probably calculating
them as well
and again I just want to make sure that
particularly newer players who are
watching this don't be discouraged if
you're feeling lost right now or you're
feeling like what am I supposed to learn
from all this I don't get what you're
saying this is normal like this is what
the night off is like and just be
patient try to pick out like what you
can if I'm saying a lion and you want to
follow it on your own board that's fine
you can pause the video and make the
moves on the board uh to help yourself
visualize but just try to follow as best
you can and I'll try to give as much
detail as possible afterward okay so
um we're gonna go and nor am I trying to
deliberately like obfuscate my thinking
this is just this is genuinely
incredibly complex complex and our
opponent is dodging all of the
minefields beautifully so we have to
play Knight takes C7 and here I don't
even spend any time considering B takes
A4 this was the exchange sack that I was
talking about it was B takes A4 Bishop
takes f8 and a takes B3 there I think
white has a ridiculously Advanced
winning move C4 we'll see if I evaluated
this correctly after the game Knight C5
Okay so
very important position
now taking the bishop here doesn't seem
promising white plays Knight takes A6
and then evacuates the Knight back
through C5
we can play Rook to B6 which is the move
that I was trying to figure out for a
while but white plays Bishop B3 there
and we don't trap the bishop because the
bishop has an exit point it can just
take Black's Bishop on E6
what are the other options available to
us well we could say okay we can see the
alignment of the Knight and the Queen
and we could try to pin the Knight with
Queen A7 or even Queen to B6 okay what
is black white gonna do there well
White's probably gonna drop the bishop
back to B3 this is sort of the bailout
option like to play Queen A7 if Queen A7
white can actually play Bishop takes B5
so if we make one of those moves it's
probably Queen B6 and I don't love the
resulting position but it's a good
bailout option to have in our pocket the
other interesting option is to play Rook
to C6
and the point of Rook to C6 is that it
targets the Knight on C5 white still has
to play Bishop B3 there I would imagine
and there maybe we can Target the Knight
again with a move like Queen B6 or queen
A7 same type of idea the
point is we we send the Rook 2 C6 first
as opposed to playing Queen B6 first
then The Rook is very awkwardly stuck on
A6 so from that perspective I like the
look of Rook C6 and if after Rook C6
white takes the Knight first we take
back with a pawn bishop B3 A4 traps the
bishop so it also sets I think a nice
trap let's go with Rook C6
we need to watch our clock here down to
five minutes but I think that's enough
time
Bishop takes A2 is a thought but
what it does after King takes A2 okay
our opponent is playing
really really magnificently so now I'm
gonna have to hunker down and play a
little faster so what do we do now
well now we have another dilemma because
if we take on B3 we double White's pawns
very likely which probably is the best
move we can also play Queen B6 straight
away but why would we succumb to damage
of our own like white we'll play Bishop
takes C6 F takes C6 and can drop the
Knight back to E4
um unfortunately the bad luck the queen
had it been on E3 would have been
indefensible by the night as it stands
94 Knight D3 guards the queen so we
can't win the night Bishop C4 blunders
the fork on D7 this is another mental
note that you have to make forkable
squares Knight D7 is a move you have to
watch for regardless of what you do so I
think we should play Bishop takes B3 now
you might say well what about Knight D7
here but it fails tactically Knight D7
here Bishop takes C2 check it can be a
bit hard to count the material in the
resulting position but it is winning for
black just trust me on that
so White's going to recapture this
bishop with what my guess is a takes B3
is the most natural move but not
necessarily the move that I knew our
player might choose a newer player might
be very concerned about doubling the
pawns and might recapture with the
Knight which would have allowed us to
fuel the fire of our attack with A4 now
we want to attack the Knight how do we
do it well again there's Queen B6 and
this time it's a bailout option because
Queen B6 basically forces an end game
Knight D3 we can trade queens and the
end game is probably about equal but are
there ways to extract more juice from
the placement of this Knight well there
is I think a nice way to do that and
that's to double the Rooks on C8 which
might strike you as like an unexpected
movement maybe like oh there is a rook
on f8 well there is and I think we
should put it to use
and I think we should play Rook F2 C8
and attack the Knight on C5 in so doing
we're taking the sting out of the move
Knight D7 which still might strike you
as a bit scary and it scares me a little
bit but now Knight D7 doesn't really do
anything we play Queen C7 we triple on
the C file remember that once that
happens C2 starts to hang and then the
Knight on D7 is stranded so intuitively
that doesn't seem dangerous to me
so white has to move this Knight B4 we
just play a takes B4 so there's no way
to defend it and legendary triple stack
so White's probably going to move it
back to D3 and in that position we have
yet another decision that we have to
make fun times what decision do we have
to make after Knight D3 like
specifically what move do we have to
decide whether to play or not to play
two Rooks for the queen so we can grab
the pawn on C2 obviously White's gonna
recapture we take on C2 and white plays
King takes C2 now I have a very strong
intuition
about whether or not to go for that line
but I'm curious to pull the crowd like
ask yourself right now this is the good
test of your intuition and this can help
you develop better instincts do you feel
like going Rook takes C2 do you think
it's a good call Practically or should
we keep the initiative and play a move
like you know H6 or maybe F6 and just
keep the pressure going on C2 and I'm
not saying that I'm right but I feel
pretty strongly that I know the answer
so my intuition is to absolutely play
Rook take C2 for Two Chief reasons the
first is that remember we get an
additional Pawn which may sound
unimportant but a pawn and a queen for
two Rooks is better than just Queen for
two Rooks all of that is the moot point
let's leave that all aside until after
the game because our opponent is
surprised us with Knight t7 now don't
fall for Rook takes C2 here because
white simply plays Queen takes E2
classic Desperado sack and our Queen
Hanks so we have to go Queen C7
now clearly I missed something here
because I don't think our opponent would
be going for this move
without seeing a follow-up because the
Knight really is you know stranded
amongst the trees but we need to be very
patient and very mindful of tactics here
because Rook to d8 actually succumbs to
this crazy idea Knight takes E5 and
white uses the back rank mate to
evacuate the Knight so just actually
incredible idea by our opponent what
does that tell us well that basically
tells me that the biggest problem for
black gear is the back rank weakness so
a move that I would be seriously
considering particularly in time
pressure is either H6 or F6 F6
kills two birds with one stone because
it secures the E5 Fawn but conversely F6
weakens the king a little bit so it's
very hard to decide between H6 and F6 we
don't want to go G6 because it creates a
hole on F6
so I'm really struggling to decide here
we're down to three minutes we also
could ignore and just attack on the
queen side but given the time pressure I
think H6 is a very wise decision
I'm gonna go with my gut here and my gut
is to play H6 my God is to not weaken
our King any further and then it needs
to be weakened H6 feels right to me
we'll check with the engine after the
game
as I said in the previous game it's not
like I have access to some hidden store
of information that helps me make these
decisions they are hard decisions
for anybody to make even a GM now I
think we have a bit of a respite
now it doesn't make sense to attack this
Knight because if we shift our Rook to
d8 well that fails tactically to Knight
F6 I actually think that the situation
has quieted down temporarily which gives
us a Tempo which we can use to further
our interests on the queen side so I
think we we should just continue our
attack right and we should play A4 we
shouldn't take our eyes off the main
goal of this position which is still to
go after White's King and we're
dangerous to low on time
now what else am I noticing here well
I'm looking at the E5 pawn and making
sure that you know white can't capture
it so I calculated 95 Queen E5 anyway
that doesn't work B4 by our opponent and
I just realized that I completely forgot
that gave him the C5 square that was a
bad move A4 was a bad move
immediately spotted by our opponent but
maybe we can play A3 and try to justify
it maybe we can play three and try to
justify no that was a very very bad move
I completely forgot that white gets the
C5 Square I might have to play a little
bit more silently
the last part of the game here because
we're getting low on time
so A3 Knight C5
yeah clearly this guy is a GM Hunter
because
yours truly is getting outplayed here
okay so maybe Knight F5 Knight T4 that
idea does come to mind Knight G6 is a
more conservative way to do that but Uh
crap that was a really bad move I
completely forgot about that okay so
let's try to reshuffle our pieces a
little bit
ah Rook C4 he's actually got Knight B6
Jesus
oh wait we have a cool line there
it doesn't work are you kidding me man I
can't seem to get anything to work here
okay let's go Knight F5 which which I
should have just played on the previous
move I mean I I don't have no idea why I
didn't see this we should have just gone
905 here and then the Knight would have
continued to be stranded on D7 just
kicking myself for that mental lapse
very very poor uh poor poor move by me
but still the position remains like
Ultra playable I don't even think black
is work well maybe black is the worst at
this point but not much worse that's for
sure because our King is now fully safe
yeah the Rooks on the D file are very
annoying but if we sidestep all the
threats carefully I think we should
still be fine I think we should still be
fine yeah I'm gonna try to bring the
magic here I can't guarantee anything
but
I will play my full strength not that I
wasn't previously but I'm gonna try
extra hard now to bring out the GM Magic
I'm trying to figure out what we do if
white plays Knight C5 that's a big
dilemma
it was C3 doesn't play it ooh but C3
looks like a juicy
move because we now have A3 ah but white
then plays Knight C5
but then we play a b i plays Rook D7
play Queen A8
terrifying
it's terrifying it's terrifying
you can also play Knight T6
you can also play Rook D6
the guitar goes the clock
okay we gotta try it
man this guy is good
okay now I gotta like super ultra Focus
Rook D6 is an option here actually not a
bad one I think
um
very very hard to decide here what to do
I'm getting I'm getting soundly
outplayed let's go Rook T6 let's try to
take some pieces off the board
he finds the move that I was afraid I
mean
okay takes but still I'm not entirely
convinced why this is bad for us Rook
takes D2 I was expecting Queen takes D2
now I thought we'd go Knight D6 and try
to repurp rotate rotate the Knight to C4
now I thought we
rotate the Knight to C4
no for sure okay but B3 incredible
strong very strong move I think to stop
night sleep we're restricting our Knight
my gosh okay what do we do now I guess
now we play Queen C6 or queen B6
okay my intuition is to play Queen to C6
in order to Target the F3 Pawn which is
one of White's main weaknesses
okay now our Pawn on A3 is a big asset
for us because yes it's a weakness but
if white takes it with the King then the
a file opens up and that gives us
potential conditions for some cool
tactics
so I'm not necessarily gonna go Rook A8
automatically if he goes King A2 I am
most worried about King A2 I think
that's a very very professional move
which is not an obvious move I think for
most players to go after this Pawn but
of course it is for this guy E4 comes to
mind trying to create some counter play
um
let's see yeah this this might be a
tough game to say but Knight B7 actually
it doesn't look half bad
maybe seven doesn't look half bad
yeah let's go Knight B7 try to take the
knights off the board exchange White's
strongest piece exchange White's
strongest piece
change White's strongest piece now King
takes A3 it's probably the best move and
the Knight takes C5 there's Queen takes
C5
yeah probably King takes A3 Knight takes
C5 Queen takes C5 is one possibility
other moves are available in this
position as well
watch my accuracy be like 60 in this
game no I really don't think it's 60 I
think it's I think it's good I think I'm
playing well with the exception of A4
which was a big very instructive mistake
but a big one
okay yeah why does white is better for
sure
white is better here
but white is better but black is very
solid I mean our king is not unsafe
there is a move that I'm really worried
about I won't say it just in case I'm
not to be totally clear I don't think
our opponent is stream sniping but just
to be totally sure there is a move that
I'm worried about here and it's another
incredibly professional move
it's a findable move and I I'm positive
he's gonna find it but
um still I I wanna okay no he didn't
find it he takes B7 which is not what I
was worried about to be completely
honest I was most worried about 94. I
was worried about 94. yeah I blow under
the sorry yeah yeah King a39 C5 Queen C5
of course there's Queen A6 check
uh winning the queen sorry about that I
was only thinking Queen takes F3 but
then the real king is objective it's
late it's late it's 5 a.m so
apologies for that
yeah this is an each Gary's training
account
but this worries me a little bit less
because now I think the position is
close to equal maybe a little bit worse
for black but I feel like we'll be able
to hold it maybe not though
maybe not
entirely possible that I'm like
misevaluating this and this was the best
line for white okay I think Queen C6
makes the most sense here targeting the
weakness 23. Jesus this guy is good okay
what do we do now how do we play Queen
F6 maybe is a very tricky move here
trying to activate the queen through H4
I really like the look of Queen F6
actually I think this might be a strong
defensive move we're trying to get our
Queen active basically my strategy in
this position with black is twofold the
first is I want to provoke white into
taking A3 I think King takes A3 would be
a huge mistake here but I'll explain it
later the second idea that we have
is to bring the queen into the attack
via H4 which I think our opponent might
have missed now Quinn F2 is a big threat
as this queen takes H2 and things are
getting very sharp unless he found he
finds some crazy defense here which I
don't see
biting tooth and nail here
trying to gather chances
yeah black is in trouble but it's like
long-term trouble it's not like white
threatens to win the game right away
it's just the long-term sort first of
all the queen trait should be avoided
here at all costs we should never trade
Queens here because White's gonna put
this Pawn mask to good use A3 is going
to fall in a rook end game and White's
just gonna create connected passwords so
mental notes itself do not allow Queen
trade under any circumstances
King takes A3 is possible but is always
going to be met with an a-file attack
obviously not right now but I'm not
worried about King takes A3
and we can also try to chip away at the
queen side yeah one person in the chat
is suggesting a move that I have in mind
which is Queen E2 we can play a move
like H5 and basically we can try to
perpetually weaken White's Queen said
whoa whoa Queen B7
that can't be the move can it now we can
take H2
probably we should take H2 I feel like
this is
logical and now we have to figure out
where to put the Rook probably we should
play
yeah my guess would we should play Rook
f8 in order to bring this Rook to a
secure Square
Rook E8 had the drawback of being a
vulnerable Square for The Rook now white
cannot take on B5 because of Rook A8
it's not made but it wins the queen
the biggest issue to me in Black's
position is the fact that we have a four
on two on the king side but but
it's hard to make a past Pawn out of it
and our King is also on that side of the
board so we can't just push our pawns
with abandon whereas White
basically can like if white plays C4 at
the right moment we might be screwed in
the long run but man if white goes C4
too soon white could very easily get
checkmated here so I don't even know
that black is worse here I don't think
black is worse uh from a practical
perspective
whose King is safer well it's impossible
currently ours obviously currently it's
hours
but there's
you know a counter balancing factor in
that like we basically cannot put our
Pawn majority to good use at all because
the moment we play a move like F5
everything opens up and uh oh it lagged
there briefly I don't like that
we cannot afford to lag out that's for
sure
yeah of course listen we can sack the F1
to push the H1 the the problem isn't in
creating a past Pawn it's that when we
create it it comes at Great cost to the
safety of our King so for example the
moment we play F5 the queen starts to
make contact with G7 so like the move
Rook to D7 might lead to Instant
Checkmate
so my strategy here with black is a bit
different it's actually to go after
White's King and to set up Checkmate
threats and threats of Perpetual check
against White's King I'm actually
forgetting for the time being about the
pawn majority and I'm looking for moves
that trap the white king in something
resembling either a meeting net or
Unstoppable Perpetual check
and once you start thinking in that
direction I think the move our opponent
might be worried about is Queen C2 and
he has good reason to be worried about
it because Queen C2 is a very deadly
threat
and the reason it's a deadly threat is
because we're trying to get the queen
over to A1 that's a checkmating square
but the additional benefit is that we
also have this check available on C1
so if after Queen C2 white plays rookie
three we have Queen C1 check forking the
King of The Rook I don't see a clear
move here for white and our opponent is
sinking almost all of his remaining time
on this
whoa what a game
it's gonna be a lot to analyze here all
right now I'm liking this a little bit
more he's down to two and a half minutes
if he gets down below a minute I think
we'll have good winning chances
like our opponent already can't do this
again what he did here take like four
minutes he can't do that again
yeah so I'm gonna
audaciously pour some more tea as our
opponent is thinking
yeah so as some of you are pointing out
it's not a disaster but if you play a
move like Queen to G1 you let the white
king Escape back to the second rank now
in that case you could deliver a check
on F2 but why give the white king more
freedom than it needs like the queen on
H2 is genius because it restricts the
king as does the B5 Pawn so it's a very
unlikely pair but notice the cooperation
between between our three pieces right
the king sorry The Rook the queen of the
B5 Pawn all of them are playing a role
in boxing in White's King on A3
the pawn is controlling A4 The Rook is
indirectly defending the pawn and the
queen is cutting the king off along the
second rank making it very difficult for
white to even move
hopefully our opponent isn't like
disconnected or something
he's down in a minute and a half now
Queen T5 is not obvious at all Piggies
on the seventh that is not an obvious
move to me Queen E4
was the more natural move to me
now I don't think that changes our plans
I think we should still go Queen to C2
trying to put a little pressure on his
clock now very important yes I see the
alignment of the Queens but obviously
The Rook has nowhere to go with check
Rook two
E3 we have a draw in our pocket now we
can give a check but I think we can play
for the win here and I think right now
do not play Rook a a check because that
loses The Rook with check but that's not
the only Avenue uh through which we can
involve our rook and we can also play
Rook to d8
and I think we're winning
I think after Rook d8 black is winning
because we're threatening Checkmate in a
couple of moves on D2 if white blocks
with his own Rook then we have Queen C2
check for king the king of the rook and
if rookie two I have to calculate this
but I think Rook D1 is winning
Rook D1 Queen ah check King H7 Queen E4
check we go G6 we end the checks I think
we can play Rook D1 and I think we've
won and we strike first with mate let's
go
what a tough game Queen A8 checking H7
Queen back to E4 we covered with G6
white runs out of checks and white is no
way to stop when A1 mate
well
yeah our opponent played definitely you
know 23 2400 level for sure and that
sometimes happens when players are a
little bit provisional
like and don't play quite as much
but big big big kudos to our opponent
that that was close and in fact the last
three games are all very close
okay
a lot to unpack both theoretically and
and in terms of uh what happened in the
later middle game
I know that I kind of sung the Praises
of this line
our opponent ended up knowing more
Theory than I did but do give this line
a chance I promise that it'll it'll
bring you a lot of success at most
levels Okay so
okay so here's a little bit of of an
overview let's go to the main nidor
position remember that in our previous
game we faced the canal attack this
should be five check and we ended up
getting into a similar structure to the
night off because white later played D4
you can watch that video separately here
we entered the main line at night of so
a little bit of history when was the
night or first laid and by whom I
actually don't know the answer to that
question let me check
and it's not necessarily neither like as
I've explained many many times like an
opening isn't always named for the first
person to play it although sometimes it
is
um it's often named for the person who
introduced the most
uh knowledge into the theory it's
actually named it's actually first
played by savelli tardukauer Antartica
hour was a grand master
and a incredibly strong player and an
opening innovator tardikauer was way
ahead of his time in his opening
repertoire he would play one f for he
played one B3 the guy was a genius
tartik hour was the first to play the
night Earth against Frederick Yates in
1926 he lost
and uh neither
wasn't neither of didn't play the night
Earth until 1939 13 years after it had
first been played it's just that he was
the most stable practitioner of the
night orphan he introduced a lot of
ideas that we now take for granted just
like the alkyne wasn't first played by
alakai himself but he kind of played it
with the most intention if that makes
sense okay
um so A6
why is the nighter of such a scary
opening to learn well largely that is
based on two things its reputation is
one of the most like crazy theoretical
lines I think stems from two important
factors the first is wait let me open
another instance of the game
the first is the complicated nature of
ideas across all nighter variations and
the fact that you have to know a ton of
different structures and a ton of
different attacking ideas and you have
to know where to trade which pieces so
strategically it's very complex but in
terms of the breadth of theory white has
literally like eight or nine moves here
that you have to know
to the teeth you have to know it by
heart what are those moves well in this
game we Face F3 Bishop to E3 is a very
similar move and often transposes into
the F3 variation if white drops the
Knight back to B3 But Here There is a
more positional line there's Knight F3
there is Bishop G5 which is widely
considered to be the most dangerous move
it's also the most popular there is the
Fisher attack Bishop C4 if caught
unaware this move can lead to very quick
victory for white there is uh the
positional Bishop B2 that was favored by
karpov and Geller among others Geller
there is H3 which became Ultra Ultra
popular in recent years and Still
Remains one of White's best weapons
there's the slightly more obscure but
still very topical F4 there's gotta
komsky's favorite line A4
there's Bishop D3 which also got very
popular lately and then there's like a
series of very provocative and rare
moves that still have to be studied H4 I
play myself in the US Championship a
couple of years back there is like A3 is
a move I faced Queen F3 with black
recently and didn't know what to do
there's Queen to D3 against Ray Robson I
played Knight to B3 and it's not like if
you don't know all of these lines you're
gonna lose out of the opening but if you
want to play the night or fall you have
to know all of these moves so just
imagine the amount of theory that and
within each of these moves there's like
a gazillion sub variations you have to
choose a line for black and you have to
study all of white subsequent setup so
it's
studying the night off is a lifelong
undertaking which is why
although I love it to death as an
opening I just don't recommend it to a
lot of people
if you want to take a crack at it there
are you know I think there's a chessable
course on the night off
but there's Anish Gary's chess up of
but it's it's a very very serious
undertaking just know that okay so in
this game uh in this analysis we're
going to focus on the English attack
exclusively with F3 okay so we play uh
E5 white plays Knight B3 and
comparatively speaking this is a pretty
narrow narrow it's narrow line
um compared to some of the other
variations where white can deviate like
on every step Here There is almost no
deviations because
yeah Knight B3 Bishop E6 is essentially
forced almost everybody plays Bishop B3
here Bishop E7 is fairly forced and here
Queen D2 is the only feasible move there
are some obscure lines but the important
thing to know and I didn't know this uh
and I lost to this as a 2100 I played
the immediate G4 I thought well why do
we need to play Queen E2 why don't we
just immediately uh it's like in
baseball right getting the lead why
don't we get the lead on the king side
attack so that when black castles you
know we go G5 quickly I'm such a genius
does anybody know the actual reason that
this is bad and there's a delicious
opening trap associated with this G4 is
a big mistake white to play Black to
play and get a big advantage
like to play and get a pretty big
advantage
it's D5 very good it's D5
white plays G5 and you push D4
white plays Jeff you play Bishop F6 and
black is better I've won a couple of
games where white goes Bishop D2 and
says well let's avoid our Pawn structure
from getting ruined this ladies and
gentlemen is one of the quickest
checkmates in the nighter I have one
Blitz Games Against title players like
this
and so what that means is white has to
go
uh the other way white has to go Bishop
F2 black plays DC you get into this end
game and obviously this end game is
better for black material is equal and
white spawn structure on both sides is
incomplete uh shambles so just very
important thing to know G4 is met with
D5 there is also the move Knight to D5
here uh but I've never been particularly
uh impressed by a black as many things
that they can do I like just Knight t5b
and Bishop F5 which is a very standard
reaction to the move Knight E5 in the
night off
and then you often drop this bishop back
and start attacking on the game side so
realistically Queen E2 is the the only
sort of serious topical line we need to
castles kingside
and Castle's Queen side okay so this is
uh starting off point for a wild mass of
theory that is the subject of its own
books
this position was first reached
in the year
1971 the first person to reach this
position with black was Robert James
Fisher against Robert Byrne Fisher was
the first to play this line with black
and Fisher this just tells you how ahead
of his time he was he understood that
the correct move is Knight bd7 he
understood to play B5 and in this
position he made an inaccuracy a move
that has fallen out of favor which is
the move Knight H5 the Knight is very
awkward here but it was played up until
the 2000s the main line as later
discovered is to counter attack white
snipe with B4 which leads to a wild wild
line white typically drops the Knight
back white attacks on the king side
black on the queen side and you
literally get chaotic unexplainable
crazy amounts of theory where both sides
are like trying to tear each other's
throat out
um what you can do if you're interested
in this you can very easily look these
lines up on on lead chess or you know on
YouTube but
part of the reason I recommend A5 is
that it it it evades The Madness of the
main lines with Knight bd7 and nb5 uh
this is totally brain melting and it's
not particularly instructive this is
where I don't like the way that some
instructors present learning openings
like there are certain openings where
you will have to devote a certain amount
of time to memorization and the process
of memorization is not itself
instructive so people often ask well I
don't want to memorize because that
doesn't help me become a better player
well you have to do it not because it
helps to be a better player but because
it's a prerequisite to playing certain
openings and this is a great example of
like where
you basically have to just memorize if
if you want to play this line just to be
totally honest but A5 is a nice
compromise because there isn't quite as
much Theory here I think the ideas are
more understandable and uh it's it's a
sideline which means white is less
likely to know uh the best moves this
was invented by a Hungarian Grandmaster
Yvonne nemetz and it was played by a lot
of GMS in like the 80s and 90s and then
it gathered momentum into the early
2000s so we're analyzing the English
attack and the sideline I propose is A5
okay so the most popular move is is in
fact Bishop B5 which is what we faced uh
in the game although it doesn't score
very well it does not score very well
um just a second
make sure I'm involving the engine here
just to just to see what the what the
top stock fish recommends nowadays after
A5
give me a second of course it's freezing
as usual
typical absolutely typical
sorry odd second here this is hard this
is this is hard to even talk about
because there's so many moving parts and
I want to try to remain instructive but
there will be some theory that we have
to get through here
because I don't think A5 is is well
explained in like chess literature so
I'm going to give you some of my own
analysis all right let's see if chessify
works this time
I mean even Hikaru I don't think would
necessarily be very comfortable in this
line okay so according to the newer
newest stockfish the best move for white
is actually to stop the pawn in his
tracks with A4 and A4 is not an easy
move for white to make because it
creates a major major hole on before and
this is actually how I like to play here
with black you can play either Knight C6
or Knight A6 but I usually play Knight
to C6
okay I might say well I get it so far
you're trying to get the Knight tv4 and
once you get the Knight to B4 not only
are you pressuring the C2 Pawn but
you're also in many cases preparing uh
D5 so it's not enough for white to know
A4 white also has to know like a crap
ton of uh supplementary Theory
oh my gosh my chest face is just like
really struggling here
okay so after Knight C6
White's best movements to play G4 black
plays Knight to B4
and most of the online games that I have
uh in this variation continue with with
G5 which is also one of uh White's best
moves and the problem is that black is
just not in time uh to play the move D5
now
the line that I really like to play
online is to drop the Knight back to E8
so what we're talking about here is
um White's best response to to the A5
variation which is A4 Knight C6 G4 and
ip4 G5
now if you run this position on the
engine uh you will find that the engine
recommendation is to play Knight H5
and the Knight potentially can access F4
but the cool moves to play online is
Knight's E8 and if white is caught
unawares by this move my success rate in
this position with black is something
like you know 75 percent
because
well if you're looking at this for the
first time who can tell me like what
seems to be natural here for white what
seems to be a natural continuation in
this position for white
yeah so I mean to me H4 seems to be the
move you play if you don't know anything
about the position because you try to
keep attacking so H4 black plays Rook to
C8 now again you don't know anything
about the position you probably play H5
black is already not worse here black
strikes at the center with D5 I've had a
ton of games that go this way now what
is the point of D5 well black is trying
to go D4 and at this point white cannot
take with the Knight because he's gonna
lose his Queen they're gonna lose our
Queen after Rook takes C2
um so white has to take with a pawn and
this is the point now the bishop drops
into F5 attacking C2 from a different
angle okay well how does white defend
this Pawn it's actually not easy to
defend this pawn and the only move that
doesn't lose is Knight B3 back to A1
all other moves simply lose the game
I've also faced Bishop to D3 a bunch of
times and here you can trade and take on
D5 forking the Knight and the pawn on F3
White's position is collapsing there's a
beautiful line where if white plays
Knight A1 here
black plays well that's not as beautiful
of a line there's Knight A2 check and
black basically has a devastating attack
um white has to find the move Knight A1
and only now do we understand why we put
the Knight specifically on E8 a couple
of moves back we now involve the Knight
via D6 we play Knight to D6 and as it
turns out this Knight on D6 becomes oops
sorry becomes a very very important
attacker because it accesses the C4
Square blockades the pawn and black has
fantastic compensation for
uh for the sacrifice for the sacrificed
Pawn that is the bottom line so for
instance
after Knight A1 Knight D6
white has a hard time finding a move
most people here they try to go after me
on the king side with G6 but I just play
F takes G6 H takes G6 and you can just
take with the bishop white is no attack
you can involve your queen you can drop
the Knight into C4 and black has
excellent long-term attacking chances
now what most people do not know is that
in this position white has a much better
move than H4 Grandmasters know this but
you know your average show is is not
going to know Theory nearly this deep
the correct move your for white which
unfortunately does kind of bust the line
is F4 F4 is incredibly strong
because white is trying to drive the
pawn up to F5 and dislodge this Bishop
from E6 so black has to react to that if
black plays e takes F4 white plays
Bishop takes F4 and the idea of this
trade is actually very positional it's
to get the the Knight the D4 Square in
the center oh if black tries to do the
same thing and we play the move Rook to
C8 black is kind of gonna run out of
attacking Firepower here this is very
very technical very technical but at
this point white can start playing H4
and black is just not in time to create
counter play if we still try to play
this D5 move after 85 Bishop F5 this is
where white has that extra resource that
they wouldn't have in the previous line
who can tell me what this resource is
this is the refutation to the uh A5
variation in the way that I play it
so I mentioned this a little bit earlier
it's not Bishop D3 we already talked
about that
um why did we play F4 think about it
that way why did we play F4
so there's two possible moves here the
sort of thematic move is Knight to D4
and if we compare
uh in this position the H4 variation
if we compare this position
with uh the position where you play F4
instead so let me just click straight
into it in this position you can see two
two Chief differences the first is that
white can now play D6 and trap the
bishop but also very convincing is the
move Knight C4 which hits the bishop
protects C2 and black runs out of active
attacking ideas
oh if you want to play this with white
this is the best line you want to go A4
but I mean this is like incredibly
esoteric I would say knowledge
comparatively speaking and if you want
to play this with black but you want to
know the best line objectively which
keeps chances alive it's actually to go
Knight H5 here
and this the position remains like
incredibly complicated I was analyzing
this a couple weeks ago and after King
B1 you want to go F6 things get very
Advanced here so I won't talk too much
about this line I'm already boring
people to death but hopefully this gives
you a little bit of context in the uh uh
in the A5 line so in in this game we
Face the main response which is Bishop
B5 this is the most popular response uh
at a human level to to the move A5
okay so A5
let me just uh I'm also making these
moves in chess space so I can tell you
the engine evals and stuff so A5 Bishop
B5
and now of course we play uh the
Thematic idea Knight to A6 getting the
Knight back to C7
okay so King B1 is a recommendation from
some old books but I actually think the
black is totally fine here at this point
according to the engine Bishop B6 and
now of course you have to know the move
Queen to B8
um and now we Face Bishop to A4 and this
was the first critical moment where I
couldn't decide between Rook A6 and D5
and D5 is actually the correct move and
we're following a game between Peter
Spindler
it is
the Russian championship 2006. this is
the only game in this position
where D5 was played in five other games
Rook A6 was played so both of these
moves are possible but stockfish does
prefer D5 at a very very high depth here
and Peter smithler did take on C7 and
the game ended in a drop so this is the
moment where our opponent deviated from
Fury by making the mistake Knight takes
D5 and this is a mistake according to
the computer
so I won't talk too much about Rook A6
other than to say that it's possible but
let's focus in this game on the Move D5
so I think our opponent just rushed
rushed in with Knight takes D5 without
realizing that he's facing the the
massive problem of the beep on advancing
to B5 and trapping the bishop the
correct move here is Bishop takes C7
Queen takes C7 now of course white can
already play e takes D5
and who can remind me how we would
respond to this move another important
idea that features frequently in this
particular line do we just move the
bishop what do we do yeah we play Rook
FTA and now a queen sacrifice that also
occurs in other lines of the night or if
White's best move this was found by
svidler is D takes E6
and after Rook takes D2
the position becomes wildly complex
white plays e takes F7 check black
recaptures on F7 and white takes back
with the knight in order to give the
bishop an attacking Avenue via B3 the
engine evaluates this with a smidge
better for white but largely it should
be a draw
black has enough activity here to keep
our King safe we play Rook to d8
smithler played A3 I mean kind of
showing that he doesn't really know what
to do black actually parked his King on
G6
which is not accurate according to the
engine according to the engine the best
move here would have been a weird move
Queen C5 actually aiming for F2
and the position is very double-edged
but essentially balanced this is an
important idea to know like a lot of top
players have lost because this sacrifice
can be incredibly strong
uh in in a lot of different positions
and I'm actually gonna find a game here
really quickly
if I remember correctly it'll show you a
good instance of where this queen
sacrifice can be winning for white
and also winning for black
yeah and and hopefully through the lens
of this analysis you're starting to
understand like this is one sub
variation of a sub variation of a
variation of the nighter right and and
we're like swimming in complications and
we're in a position that hasn't even
been reached before and still yet you
have to know this because this could
very conceivably be reached you're
starting to see just the breadth of
theory that that you have to know and
why why these things take people like
years to to actually learn and even then
you don't like fully learn it
Okay so I actually was wrong white ended
up losing this game which is good why
was uh I I don't you know I don't love
showing Kuryakyn games but but still
with our primary motive here is to
provide instructive value so there was a
famous game this game was very very
popular at the time that it was played
it was kayaking against Anand in uh Wake
On Zay 2007. and in that game
in that game
uh vicious played the main line here he
played Knight bd7 and they went down uh
the sort of the main path
92 98 this is the crazy line that I was
talking about except karyakan played H4
and vishi played A5 King B1 Knight B6
I'm quickly gonna get to the critical
position they were making moves blah
blah blah D5 and guess what happens here
Bishop takes B6 Queen takes B6 and if
you're paying attention and you should
know the course that the game takes
karyakan takes on D5 vishy pins the pawn
and uh karyakin he first played Bishop
C4
the Knight hits the pawn and kuryakin
decided at this point to sack his Queen
with d takes C6 Rook takes D2 ef7
checking h8 Rook to two with a crazy
position that is approximately equal
which Vision won in the end so this
queen sack exists in several different
variations of the English attack this
game was like very hotly debated and
analyzed when it was played because the
night off was like huge at the time our
instance of the sack is pretty similar
and also leads to a complex uh position
but our opponent of course plays a
knight takes D5 so let's uh focus on
that move instead okay so we play Knight
takes D5 and the engine already shows a
winning advantage or black in this
position the question is what did we do
wrong because clearly I messed this up
you will not believe this you will not
believe what the top engine move is
after Queen F2 I can give you five
attempts collectively as a chat to find
the engines the like strong engines
assessment here
but there is also a move that makes a
lot more sense to me which is also very
difficult oh what an incredible idea
so the top
the top suggestion is H6
just rubbing it all over White's face
that that they can't do anything here
but the second engine
recommendation is gorgeous and also
leads to a winning position for black
it's the move Bishop to d8 which I saw
this is a sensible idea right you force
the trade you have to take and uh well
what do we want to do here we want to go
B5 why did I reject this well I rejected
this because you're giving white a Tempo
what can white use this Tempo to do well
we already know that this becomes a big
problem because this allows the bishop
to evacuate via B3
but what's incredible is that in this
position black is not obliged to
recapture
and black has the ridiculous move B5
right away
now you're like my head is spinning I
don't know what's going on black is
completely winning here and here's the
reason why
both Bishops are hanging let's consider
the options of moving both of them if
white moves the Bishop from d8 then it's
all very very simple B takes A4 Knight
C5 and of course there is this Fork
Knight C3 using the B file
if white tries to Desperado give give
away the other Bishop it's essentially
the same thing I mean black plays Queen
takes B5 now white has to move the
Bishop from d8 and it's the same exact
thing black plays either A4 or Rook even
Rook fc8 is very strong because the
attack on whites King is gonna be
completely Unstoppable like all of the
pieces are just converging on White's
King
so just
I saw Bishop d8 but B5 was completely
not on my radar and what's so
interesting about this is that a couple
of weeks ago
yes a couple weeks ago I did a lecture
at the chess camp that I was teaching in
Atlanta on avoiding autopilot moves and
I identified like a couple of instances
where autopilot moves are the most
common and one of those instances is
automatic recaptures so one of my like
biggest takeaways from that lecture was
avoid automatic recaptures because you
never know when a tactical opportunity
can uh manifest itself and the game that
I showed to to illustrate
that concept was a capablanca game that
has nothing to do with the topic at hand
but just to show you really really
quickly what game I chose to illustrate
that
so it was the following game this is
going to be a long video
so I will not be offended if you go to
bed or you don't remain for all of it
I promise
all right so here is the Kappa blanca
game that I showed to illustrate this
concept
the point is this in this position Kappa
takes the pawn on B7 and black plays
Bishop takes Knight on F4
and obviously the the autopilot move
here is to play GF
but then I'll I'll kind of give you the
elevator pitch here black is able to
reach a drawable end game so you have to
say wait a second is the recapture Force
once you realize that it isn't you're
able to find a sequence of really really
pretty in-between moves who can come up
with the winning idea here for white
this is a great exercise for you to
train your Advanced tactical awareness
if you're watching on YouTube you start
with rookie one check
but that looks like a blunder because
black can cover with the bishop
and now you strike with D6 check
the bishop is pinned the queen is pinned
the king can't take because of Rook D1
if the king steps back black gets
checkmated here with Queen B6 and Rook
C1
and if the king moves forward then the
queen retreats to B3 again if the king
takes then Rook T1 wins the queen if the
King goes to F5 there's check check
um and here Kappa Blanca wins with check
check win the queen because if black
goes the other way if black goes to H5
there's G4 and queen H6 mate all of this
had to be calculated by Kappa Blanca
when he played rookie one in fact when
he played Queen takes B7
so long story short this is a well-known
situation in which our brains are often
incapable of even generating uh an
alternative to the automatic recapture
and the more like natural the recapture
the harder it is to find a move like B5
I would show you that blind spots
persist all the way to GM level it's
totally natural to have these blind
spots and you shouldn't feel that you
know I have it all figured out
tactically this is instructive for for
me as well so that was our big mistake I
played Rook A6 which to me is a much
more natural move
um but this relinquishes all of the
advantage
this relinquishes all of the advantage
after Rook A6 the evaluation according
to the engine
is only a small Advantage for black
actually now it's showing basically
equality okay so that was the missed win
we played B5 white plays Bishop takes C7
here I did see the possibility of B
takes A4 because it's another capture
and after B takes A4 the position that I
was struggling to evaluate is Bishop
takes f8 a takes B3 like how on Earth do
you evaluate a position like this and
the evaluation is actually equal the
move that I was worried about is C4
which is a crazy move it counter-attacks
the Knight and I was worried that
Black's attack Fizzles out now you guys
should understand that in such positions
you almost never want to play Pawn takes
Pawn because white is going to use the
umbrella method and just hide behind the
pun by keeping the pawn on B3 you're
opening yourself up to many more
attacking options so here the correct
move is to play Knight to B4 threatening
like a smothered mate white has to take
that Knight
and now black throws an intermezzo
forcing the king into the corner because
if the King goes the other way if the
King goes over to C1 then you play B
takes A2 and the pawn is basically
Unstoppable now you play a B threatening
Checkmate on A2 white has to go A3 and
the attack is Unstoppable after Pawn
takes spawn you're threatening to take
on B2 and play Rook 2 A2 check
and to and to win the game with a
straightforward
uh straightforward attack very very
simple
nothing particularly complicated in any
of these lines but because I was totally
unsure of how to evaluate this position
I decided to err on the side of being
more conservative and so I decided just
to grab uh the bishop on E7 and play
this position probably a mistake in
retrospect uh because according to the
engine this is a very promising position
for for black white has to play the com
Bishop C5 black plays BC of course King
takes C2 is out of the question and here
white black plays Rook C6 I did see this
position in my mind and also didn't know
what to make of it apparently in order
to keep equality white has to
countersack The Exchange and go Rook to
one this is just engine BS I don't think
anybody would play that Rook C1 is a
mistake because of Queen C8 creating the
hidden threat of Bishop F5 pitting the
queen to the king and if white moves the
king into the corner then suddenly
Knight B4 comes with a great effect
because if white plays Queen A4
who can answer the following question
can black play Rook take C5 why or why
not the H6 business that move that the
engine mentioned H6 I think it's just
like a preliminary Loft move because
Bishop d8 will be coming next yes you
can take on C5 because at the end of the
line you can block with a queen and
reach a technically winning end game
with two pieces for a rook ridiculous
levels of tactical complexity all of
this hinges on these like minute details
and that's what makes this opening so
exciting but I decided to avoid this
particularly because we were in time
pressure at this point
um so Knight takes E7 Knight to C5
only move Rook to C6 which is I think
totally natural Bishop B3 and the engine
gives equality here Bishop takes B3
a takes B3 Rook F to C8 attacking the
Knight and amazingly Knight D7 is
actually the only correct move I have to
give our opponent massive Kudos because
I was expecting Knight to D3
but after Rook takes C2 just so you know
the engine eval in this position and if
you're watching on YouTube you should
pause and try to evaluate this position
like do you think black is slightly
better do you think it's equal
what is the actual evaluation here
so it's winning for black it's plus
three and the reason it's plus three as
I explained during the game is that the
king is essentially weak forever
even if it hides on B1 black is always
going to be able to play A4 and open up
the queen side Black's Knight has
tremendous prospects in the center so
you go Knight F5 the King has to escape
now you make some lifts with H5 just so
there's no back rank problems
and White's Rooks are also kind of
biting on granite particularly the one
on E1 then black is gonna go Knight T4
Black is going to go A4 and you are
eventually going to get to this King
so I don't want to give get too
technically here because we have more
stuff to talk about but definitely in
this position we would have taken on C2
and the queen is much much better than
the two Rooks because of how exposed uh
Whites Whites Kings okay
so 1987 is correct
amazing uh black plays Queen to C7
and white plays Rook td2 he has to
defend the pawn on C2 now we played H6
which the engine likes it's one of the
top moves just making a little bit of
Loft white plays Rook H to D1
and here a very fateful moment where I
made a very big mistake A4 is in fact a
big mistake after B4 it's plus over
minus black is in serious trouble after
I made that move
um the corrective appear would have been
in fact the immediate Knight F5 as like
I had indicated during the game trying
to get the Knight to an outpost on D4
and now the engine line is crazy it goes
G4 Knight T4
now white to play and find a pretty
simple tactic who can spot like you know
pretty stock tactical move here that
leads to liquidation
it's yeah Knight takes E5 removing the
defender
now you can achieve a draw several ways
with black you can play Queen takes E5
or you can counter sacrifice on B3 this
is a Desperado and it leads to a
liquidation takes takes takes takes and
finally the Smoke Clears and it's
basically a draw because the position is
like largely symmetrical so that would
have been a natural conclusion to the
game instead I played A4 overzealous
forgot that white gets this evacuation
Square not
evacuation Square you know it's like a
helicopter that flies to evacuate you
but it's like a Ritz Carlton Hotel room
inside that helicopter so once the
Knight gets to C5 it's like a permanent
Outpost and then the Rook dives into D7
and black is suddenly in big trouble
here I found the only move that doesn't
lose on the spot Knight F5 our opponent
plays the move C3 guarding the D4 square
and now A3 once I realized that I was in
trouble I knew that I have to play very
very actively in order to generate
concrete counter play and after Knight
C5 yet another very very difficult
decision and here I made another mistake
after Rook D6 White's position is
technically winning
although the mistake started to come in
bunches here G4 is also inaccurate white
should have simply played B takes A3 and
black has essentially no compensation at
this point for the sacrificed Pawn white
dominates the D file and black is
running out of ideas
what would have been the correct move
here and why did I not play it well the
correct move would have been a takes B2
why didn't I play that move what was I
scared of well I was scared that the
Rook would infiltrate D7 and that my
queen could potentially get trapped and
in fact it does get trapped if you play
Queen B6 there's Rook B7
and if you guys want to see a beautiful
line
here black has a devilish defensive
resource
let's see who can find this resource but
then who can also find White's response
which keeps the queen trapped
this is a very very difficult move
but you can try to guarantee the Queen's
safe passage to d8
by playing
not Rook A8 because here you play Rook
B6 this is an empty check in white wins
but Rook to d8 which is a hard move to
wrap your head around like wait what if
white just takes the queen but now you
take the Rook with check and remember
light can't go up to C2 and attack The
Rook because because you're gonna
promote so white has to waste time
taking you take on B6 and you have two
Rooks for the queen position is unclear
but white does not have to engage right
you don't have to respond to the email
why does it have to engage white can
just go Rook G1 or Rook F1
which is another hard move to see
because you just leave the open file but
Black's Queen remains trapped Now The
Rook is in the Queen's way
um don't have to respond to chat exactly
so therefore what that means is that you
have to go the other way you have to go
to B8
and what I was worried about here is
that white would essentially Checkmate
us on the F7 Pawn I saw this move and I
like crapped my pants because Queen to
D5 is a huge threat
our pieces are super passive and
according to the engine black can hold a
draw here but with some crazy ideas like
black has to find this move I already
did not see this move because from a
distance I thought that there was a fork
how could I have missed the simple Rook
takes D7 Queen D7 Queen A8 only move
defending the Rook attacking the Knight
and black is somehow surviving Walking
the Tightrope and actually winning in
this position
so after Rook C7 black is only slightly
worse
just ridiculous and not particularly
instructive so let's actually get to the
game Rook to D6
here G4 kind of gave us a new lease on
life because after Rook takes D2 I think
what our opponent might have forgotten
about is that Queen takes D2 allows the
Knight to jump to H4
attacking White's only Pawn weakness on
F3 and therefore keeping uh the material
balance so white was forced to take with
a rook but now the Knight is able to
potentially access the C4 Square which
which means B takes A3 is no longer good
here due to Knight C4 that is the
difference right that is why white
should have taken immediately here if
black plays Rook takes D2 the queen
captures on D2 and keeps the Knight out
of commission the Knight is unable to
access this Outpost because white
dominates the D file forever
okay
so subtle difference here therefore
white was forced to change their plans
and play B3
but now with the A3 Pawn comes long-term
counter play and I played Queen C6 our
opponent very professional King A2
Knight B7 and this is I think the final
critical moment in the game I think this
is the moment where white missed his
last chance to get essentially a
technically winning position
so our opponent traded and it's still
better for white but it's very very
unconvincing the correct move here was a
difficult one to make who can tell me
what it is
who can tell me what the correct move is
Knight C5 to E4
and the point of this move as my coach
would say is to play for Domination this
is a hard concept for a lot of people to
understand and I think this position is
a great window into how players of
different levels approach the same
position so let's take three levels like
beginner level intermediate advancing my
point is never to denigrate a beginner I
think in fact it's the contrary it's a
show like what you have in store for you
so I think a newer player would look at
this and say okay well uh the knights
are are facing each other but I don't
really see the benefit of trading on B7
so let's just take let's take A3 that
seems like a free Pawn now it's not a
free Pawn because black has Knight takes
C5
and if the queen recaptures then black
wins the queen which I missed during the
game
but that's not even that important
because if the pawn recaptures black
plays rookie a check King B2 and after
Queen to A6 black gets a devastating
attack down the a file so in fact white
has to leave this Pawn on A3 using the
umbrella method an intermediate player
would operate like our opponent did and
say okay well we have to trade Knights
because otherwise we lose the C3 Pawn so
let's trade Knights and play a general
improving move just to defend the C3
Pawn okay this is an advantage
but sure would say okay the Knight on B7
is on the worst Square
of the entire chessboard and this is an
opportunity for white to assert complete
positional dominance by playing Knight
to E4 notice the role played by the G4
pawn it prevents black from playing F5
and pushing away the Knight the Knight
on B7 cannot rejoin Society in any
meaningful way
black has no moves and no ideas you can
try to take a pair of Rooks off the
board
but after the Rooks are traded NY plays
Queen C5 black is just collapsing the B5
Pawn is ultra weak A3 can now be
captured and Black's end game is Dead
lost
so I can probably find examples of moves
like this if I looks hard enough but
I've talked for long enough so I'm gonna
I'm gonna run a quick search and see if
I can find a similar idea
see
E4
say black has a knight on B7
yeah definitely there are actual
examples of like moves like this
but I'd have to look a little bit harder
to
uh to to to actually find a meaningful
example
yeah I'm seeing a lot of examples of
this move being played but the basic
idea is to play for Domination
um and to use your pieces to restrict
the mobility of your opponent's pieces
94 is
an incredible move and it just shuts
down all of Black's ideas probably I
would even plant move like Rook 8 here
and try to grovel
and here it's actually not so easy for
white to finish black off like you want
to improve your position slowly Rook D3
black has nothing better than to shuffle
now Queen D2 it's very instructive to
see how the engine wins these types of
positions very patiently Rogue T5
nothing crazy just like moves that step
by step induce a weakness and now you go
Queen D3 and you win the B5 Pawn like
black collapses on one of several fronts
and this is because the B7 Knight is
totally out of the game and that is a
series that I want to do at some later
Point like get a bunch of players and
compare how they approach the same
position thank you slim G for the sub in
any case after the trade of knights I
think black has excellent practical
chances to save the game
and obviously we ended up winning the
game and we won the game really because
of the mistake I made at the very end
Rook D3 Queen F6 notice what I'm doing
I'm not even trying to defend this spawn
because I understand that anytime white
takes it we can give a check and swing
the queen over and the a-file attack is
at the very least going to give us
practical compensation
what I'm trying to do instead is seek
maximum activity for my pieces how do I
approach that well there's two forms of
activity there's one that comes from
attacking your opponent's weaknesses
this is what I was trying to do on C6
and then the other form of activity is
essentially infiltration you're trying
to detect which Avenues you can take for
your pieces to aim to infiltrate the
enemy territory so in this case there's
only one Avenue when you see this Pawn
construction you know that there are
some dark Square weaknesses and so
that's how I was able to find this queen
Pathway to H4 just trying to get the
queen as active as possible and after
Queen f60 the engine already throws
equality it's already equal
Queen E4 Queen H4
Queen B7 is another mistake and now
black is better
here black is already better so White's
last chance to maintain the balance
would have been to drop the Rook back to
D2 and the game continues but here our
opponent lost the thread Queen B7 Queen
H2 King A3 Rook f8
and um already it's almost impossible to
defend this without uh without an engine
Queen E4 Queen C2 it's still not losing
for white until he played uh the panic
mode rookie three there was an only move
here that's almost unfindable and that
is C4 and this gives white chances to
hold the game black is only slightly
better because if black plays Queen B1
to threaten checkmate you don't go Queen
E2 that blunder is made in one you go
Rook D2 and somehow white is still
holding on amazingly check Rook B2
because the queen holds the A8 Square
according to the computer oh what a move
there's Queen E3 here that's the top
engine move
Queen to E3 are you freaking kidding me
and you need to play this move only
after the white Rook gets to B2
because it deprives the king of the
Escape Square ridiculous
this is Checkmate on the next move
but white is able to hold by playing the
incredibly calm Rook B1
renewing the threat of Queen takes E3
black can check on A7 black and check on
F2 so the attack continues the attack
rages on but black is not like winning
by force here
after King A3 Rook d8 is winning because
of this uh idea but white has to go King
C3 so at some point the position becomes
indefensible for a human and most of
these positions that involve a
permanently weakening like this are
impossible to defend unless you're
Magnus Carlson or you have or your
stockfish or you have three hours on
your clock and can't blame our opponent
for missing Rook d8 I think what
happened was he was fixated on
preventing Rook a gate and forgot that
there are other avenues other ways to
get to whites King so ultimately we end
up striking first and here our opponent
resigned because the checks run out very
quickly and there's no way to stop Queen
A1 check me
oh my God what a ridiculously
complicated game with so many different
stages
so a couple of takeaways if I could even
dare speak in those terms so in this
game we followed the English attack I
don't know if I'll repeat the night off
again just because this was a crazy
undertaking we focused on the English
attack and we focused on the sideline A5
evading the main line which goes Knight
bd7 and then B5
so the point of A5 is to push this Pawn
up to A4 we'll probably get a chance to
Play It Again
what I didn't talk about here is moves
that are not Bishop B5 or A4 and there's
plenty of those moves like King B1 is a
popular move here and black is in fact
supposed to push the pawn all the way up
to A3 and induce weaknesses but I think
we've had enough theoretical uh
Exposition for one day a lot of like
newer players go G4 here because they
don't really sense the danger inherent
in pushing the Knight away to A1 and
here again you play A3 and then Knight
A6 Knight B4 followed by D5 it's this
like typical idea
so I showed you what the best line is in
my opinion which is A4
then we looked at the actual game
continuation
we saw that our opponent's main mistake
was Knight takes D5 instead Bishop C7
leads to a wild unbalanced position
we understood that Rook A6 As Natural as
it is was a mistake bishop d8 and B5
avoid autopilot moves is a good takeaway
from this particular segment of the game
then things were relatively tame until
the night landed on D7 that's when
things got crazy again we looked at some
cool lines I made a very serious mistake
in playing another autopilot move A4 I
thought this was good based on general
principles but I didn't stop to consider
what B4 gave our opponent
which was this massive outpost on C5
then Black's position becomes very dire
I make another mistake in playing Rook
to D6
then another series of inaccuracies
particularly Knight p7 which would have
allowed Knight E4 here white is still
winning
but once the knights are traded black
was able to find counter Play We
activated Our Queen we got the queen
into the attack forced the white king to
take the poisonous pawn and ultimately
used multiple directions to finish off
the attack
crazy game and I know if you're watching
this on YouTube first of all thank you
for making it to the end
this was all over the place
tons of complexity but
this is a taste of what
of why chess is like a ridiculous game
because because this is just one tiny
corner of one tiny line of one tiny
variation and this already can be
analyzed for 10 15 hours this game this
line and the night off is one of the
openings that opens the Pandora's Box
because the position is so unbalanced
and with opposite side castling by
definition you get complexity because
both sides are attacking and defending
all at the same time
and so structurally tactically the
positions are wild chaotic and can be
studied for many many years
so if you want to open that box then
play the night off look at Anish giri's
chessable course that would be my
recommendation it's pretty accessible
relatively speaking but for newer
players that is why I recommend a more
uh relatively speaking Tamer Sicilians
such as the accelerated Dragon which is
easier to understand and easier to learn
all right guys on that note I'm gonna
head to bed urgently because I have
title Tuesday in the morning and I don't
want to miss it I'll be doing it in
Russian in the morning and then in
English in the afternoon
I hope you enjoyed the game I apologize
for all the long-windedness and uh you
know if if the theory was too much but
I'm just honestly trying to give you a
window into what chess looks like at
this level without sugar coating it and
I there's nothing I hate More Than
People pretending that it's all very
easy or that memorization isn't required
this is what you're gonna have to do if
you want to hit you know 22 2300 rapid
and
you know this work has its redeeming
components as well thanks everybody see
you guys later goodbye
[Music]